political activists favorite tool
whatsapp it's forwarding feature is so
handy but we found it being exploited to
spread anti labor messages among British
Indians we've seen more than 20 messages
saying pass this to every true Indian no
self-respecting Hindu should vote the
Labour Party full stop the Labour Party
is now the mouthpiece of the Pakistani
government it's a divisive tone worrying
for observers I've seen those kind of
messages come out of India and Indian
politics quite a lot because I follow
South Asian politics closely so what was
surprising to me was that that sort of
politics is wholeheartedly wholesale
come over here and that I think should
be ringing alarm bells in this country
who's sending these messages
one person is this man Sushil Dogville
who stood as a Conservative councillor
in 2018 he sent this message complete
with spelling mistakes to his local
parties what's that group Sadiq Khan and
Corbin are against Jews Hindus and
following hidden agenda of jihadis
conservatives should unite to take back
Britain from Corbin Sadiq when I spoke
to mr. doke file over whatsapp he said
this was posted to me and I posted to my
colleagues to know what's happening if
true then study it and maybe to learn
from it a Conservative Party
spokesperson told us the matter is under
investigation
other British Indians say they're just
defending India like Rashmi who's in
dozens of whatsapp groups we have 5 to 6
whatsapp group which have lots of
Indians I would say not only Hindus but
people from all religion irrespective of
the party politics community leaders
they are all talking about one thing but
that is about being Indian and how to
save India from being tarnished in UK
this isn't the first time whatsapp's
been linked to divisive politics during
the 2019 indian election won by Narendra
Modi's nationalist BJP the app was
accused of fostering polarization
in response what's that reduce the limit
for forwarding from 20 to 5 groups first
in India then worldwide its spokesperson
told us whatsapp is absolutely committed
to helping to tackle the problem of
viral misinformation we will continue to
prioritize the development of new ways
to help us address this issue in the
future
whatsapp is just the latest social media
app to come under scrutiny you have to
wonder can divided British politics
handle their disruptive influence roller
Man top Sky News